So first, let's talk about our motivation.
As many previous works pointed out, misinformation campaigns are manipulating public opinions on hotspot topics, such as COVID-19 epidemic and vaccines.
For example, a publication pointed out that in those places where misinformation from misinformation campaigns spread faster, the vaccination ratio of these places is also
relatively lower than other places.
So, to design mitigation strategies to reduce user susceptibility to misinformation, we have to understand how misinformation influence user beliefs and activities.
However, most of the existing works suffers from one or more of the following limitations.
So first, almost all the data-driven methodologies or data-driven analysis focus on correlation between misinformation and user activities.
And it is well known that causality is different from correlation.
So they cannot distinguish causal effect of misinformation from user prior beliefs.
Let us use the case of misinformation and the vaccination ratio.
One explanation could be that in this place, people primarily don't trust vaccines, so they don't take vaccines and they spread a lot of misinformation.
That could be true, but the correlation analysis cannot help us distinguish them.
And there are some other works trying to understand the real causal effect.
But they mainly rely on random controlled experiments and surveys.
So, first, they are very expensive.
And secondly, they may bring some ethical risk if we apply them on very huge social media platforms.